è ovvio che se non la rai va a [ __ ]
[Musica]
tra i traditori tra i 33 broker loro e
se vuole che dentro il live
però in realtà stiamo facendo questo
live proprio perché oggi stiamo facendo
questo singolo di lifestreaming si
sentirà originale si sente
se se non sbaglio da quelle live si
sente regalare insieme e da lo so
comunque si sente adesso siamo siamo in
teoria in live
ci vedrete raga adesso si sente semi
live online e offline aspetta un
ricarico dovranno essere il live
ok semplicemente non ci si vede ma loro
siano dal vivo che è il tornatore
ciao ok siamo ritorna siamo ritornati
borga [ __ ] mother father ora si sentirà
ditemi se sentite questa canzoncina
bellissima
mettere questa qua
però lì non si sente di continua
ok quindi il caso del gatto son capture
lo prende mamma mia di quanto caldo fa
vero
[Musica]
proprietà
secondo me ce la faccio senza farti del
male
non ce l'ho fatta
mai prendere
[Musica]
che poi è la tarantella siciliana
a ridere secondo ma lo sai che io ti ho
detto no no no danzata e ballata per
tantissimo tempo veramente la ciura il
passo con una così bella siciliana sono
orgogliosi orgoglio qualche modo di te
se io non mi piace incrocio si chiama
io sto tentando di risolvere i problemi
di audio out pietro puzza grazie crono
xz anch'io un 50 euro per dire che
pietro puzza
vabbè
grazie della donazione magari compreso
delle casse migliori visto che stiamo
tentando solo di risolvere un problema
di audio iniziale tanto per cambiare a
gesù grazie mille crono adesso
risolveremo
il problema e non so come risolvere
semplicemente il quale la edil hanno
semplicemente questo è il problema
eppure dirà
strano dai ma quindi
aspetta socio che mi capire quale
problema
si sente dicono ti dicessi sento no non
si sentono
di questo quello delle legato deve
andare avanti
se non va perché un problema di chi è
che problema può esserci claudio paielli
può succedere ma forse si aspetta che
disse
no non è quello
dovrebbe andare l'audio di qua ma non
c'è non sai che ti dico cosa mi dico che
è legato
lo devo riavviarli attivare aspetta lo
faccio e strano si deve sentire perché
non si sente
sentiti
mannaia la morte perché mai non si
dovrebbe sentire se si è sentito la
settimana scorsa in loop il loop
se si è sentita la settimana scorsa
nora che non si sente guidate
cioè si sente ma lontano ditemi se fiera
di te vi sentite adesso non sentito e
scommetto sentite adesso se non sentite
si sente adesso in questo momento ditemi
se sentite bene ma non sentite perché
qua ci dovrebbe essere la
perché tutti scrivono di sì perché si
sente la nostra qua ma la sentono
lontana adesso adesso abbassato volume
se lo sentono adesso perfetto inizia a
giocare ma fidati che non si sente
perché qua dovrebbe apparire stato dato
da forse loro sentono noi ma non stiamo
chiedendo ragazzino se noi ci sentiamo
noi stessi senza scegliere l'audio del
del computer noi che ci sentite lo
sappiamo che un incidente nell'audio del
gioco non si sente e non so il motivo le
cuffie dimetto perché strano se così
veri che non si sente lo stato ha detto
che non si sentiva no non si sente
infatti ho detto
se andava da settimana scorso sei andato
in tutte le live deve andare anche oggi
non è che oggi non va
grazie neko per la donazione
sono molto lusingato
sei molto gentile dobbiamo risolvere
questo problema e poi vi ringrazio per
bene allora come potremmo anche giocare
dal mo anche giocato all'audio entra qua
mi serve thomas
chiamiamo il tecnico allora il tecnico
delle live
tonica picciano cosa non ho bruciato
chiamerò il tecnico delle live si
risolverà il problema e poi entrare poi
entreremo il die
ciao raga e l'ora il tuo amico è
fidanzato
no
è
entrata entrata si niente mi dispiace si
sono fidanzati dispiace mi spiace amerà
livia in cui guardano
amico mio scusami se ti disturbo
ti devo chiede una roba al volessimo
sono in live in questo momento quindi
salutato tutti la prima cosa ma anch'io
è la se anche giampiero e la seconda
cosa ma senti come che si sente l'audio
da me è però non si sente agli altri
cioè di un altro computer e ubs cioè il
gatto a zero non
la bara l'audio non va però nel mio
computer si sente tutto benissimo e
anche il sound capture da che che si
sente l'audio è solo di laghi non si
sente
non sente il gioco no no ma a me mi
sentono a me minuti però di là
nell'altro computer non non arriva
l'audio del del computer solo con
l'audio del computer
la rotella delgato dove
si è
non lo sapesse
proprietà proprietà dispositivo game
capture
aspetta
preparando e non si muove la paghetta
però io sento sul mio
sì sì sì le barrette si muovono le
barrette si muove
dove vuoi sentire il gioco
è sotto metto la capture carnola
stiamo stiamo risolvendo la chiave
è grande
[Musica]
ma
allora il canale di thomas
paga era colpa mia
se la colpa mia ok non sono capaci a
fare di più per ok va bene grazie
dalla copertina del video si doveva
intuire questa titanica
adesso si può giocare
torniamo siete arrivate mi problemi
tecnici nel frattempo con questi
probabili tecnici ho fatto più soldi in
donazioni che in tutte le altre live dei
premi non c'è però grazie no seriamente
ragazzina così tanto
non so mai cosa dire pietro puzza retro
curata sia in grande per grazie
se mi chino cago per il treo ringrazia
grazie dato grazie manuel grazie io sono
7 grazie eneko per altri 50 euro così
brava un bacino grazie e san juan ciao
raga loreto amico è fidanzato abbiamo
fatto prima
ciao manu chao ha dato ciò mi disse
glory per fare un video dove così launch
pad sì però sono video
elaborati quindi non lo posso fare
adesso grazie marica grazie dado di
assoluta che lo chiede rivolte si aiuta
sempre nel club degli dei vuoi fare
vedere la città dai facciamo ci vado per
chi non lo conoscesse questo tool
schiacci tasti e la [ __ ] arriva serve a
questo
però adesso non lo fai anche tantissimi
colori non lo faremo perché roberta e
gelato però funziona arriva roberto
esatti
non so quanto giampiero secondo in
particolare questa cosa questa cosa va
bene possiamo cominciare a giocare
scusatemi il problema tecnico
però io sono fa vj mitrano scene da
brocchi perdoniamo grazie perdoni grazie
grazie
mi dispiace non fa di solito sono molto
più bravo di così
non tantissimo però aspetto che metta
fine al contrario già abbiamo problemi
di noi facciamo caso che gli aggiungiamo
il quadrato il quadrato il quadrato e
sbaglia al quadrato è sparito stavolta
senza che facessi non ho intanto
sparisce perché ci ha voglia io non
capisco neanche io non voglio capire me
l'ha insegnato il gatto che si toglie
con il sensore è sì perché io mica lo
sapevo che ero per quello va bene ci
chiede allora adesso per sentire tutti e
due dovremmo ottenere grassi nicole per
la donazione come che milano le ragazze
a me ragazze mi danno dei soldi che
quale ragazza vorrebbe essere al mio
posto tutti penso di sì grazie le
ragazze anche se un euro e un caffè che
mi offre grazie di cole ricambiato il
favore
giochiamo l'uno
e uomo
allora avvertenza per l'as quando il
gioco salva sì quello l'abbiamo capito
mi dici una cosa sincera dà fastidio che
la luce sia così bianca nei miei video
in generale allora se thuram etico si no
perché cosa succede alla luce va dritto
e riflette e non è così bianca
settore aggiri quello del futuro dove si
girare liberamente bianco quindi è però
esce lago si fida di me ma così va bene
l'uscita banks e allora veramente io
c'ho sempre problema che secondo me non
è lucia fa schifo lo guarda suo vice
è questo salvataggio e questo è stata da
giudici hanno fatto prima l'ho fatto un
giro non ci credo e spero
scontro è vero e non hanno fatto prima
mentre mai
dunque oggi el 11 15 non c'ho pensato
comunque
leggi questo commento non dire niente
per il boca ed ora giulia grazie alla
donazione
bravissima cioè l'unico dispositivo ma
vabbè ciao giulia grazia sinagra il tuo
pensiero potrà avverarsi ma lei non è
vero stiamo scherzando
l'avventura narrativa influenzata dalle
scelte dei giocatori ti voglio bene
anch'io dato grazie mille delle nazioni
grazie giada ti adoro anch'io grazie
spot t red che celebra il ragazzo
allora i parte allora milano mila 2017
ciò ambiente
[Musica]
chi semina
persone iberici
magari non è che con la faccia
ma dai
per richiuderla non si sa
ora
e mio zio
magari non sempre
dynamo e speriamo io
disse che dio
qui davanti
di molti adesso
io ero preso non ho mai capito grazie
alla nazione ciao marzia sto molto bene
ieri
seguite gianpiero
secondo
lo è tornato fra che cosa mammamia
ricreata milano la perfezione già notare
albaro
senza
sì
allora alzo alzo al fumo di quale
ok
è successo era un solo abbassato
vaio in classifica segnato di più
durante che ora striscia tutte
una di cui solo educazione fisica mi
legava un popolo che gli tira miele
si gioca guardando
una scritta
ti prego voglio vedere il self durante
la lezione umana e trasferisce
a max
con uno specchio
macchina
sì
lo sapevo lo sapevo lo sapeva lui
mamma mia ma l'uomo ha dei problemi
comunque perché ce l'ha con me a
prescindere però io sono un york
è vero
esiste adesso ho mosso e venduto ma
appunto di o me ne vado vado
basket
singer vuoi
la barba guadagnato niente
devo proprio
a
max
l'iphone
è
[Musica]
bello
only polaroid
sì l'ho detto proprio perché diciamola
sono una donna povera ti offro 2 che
aspetta geniale grazie mister alpo
quindi dubito enjoy
grazie mille graziando grazie dato certo
perché evidentemente non conosce i
problemi grazie ciao paolo
vabbè ma sono tutti arrabbiatissima
costit siamo la m normale poi tra
qualche anno
la sua
schermo ricordavo
delle scarpe giuste no
[Musica]
sì molto scolpito di mangialamusica
della musica sì perché una freccia in
cul e vero ci pensa la controllo
immediatamente perché centore per terra
tra
[Musica]
avete vorrei parlare l'interesse adesso
noi interessa il mio armadietto mai
guardano
ma perché moglie
perché
e prima ehi ehi ma qualcosa tra qualche
anno tanto
allora la smetti guardare
[Musica]
pesa 110 libri perché se tu vuoi una
persona che solitamente non è proprio
lei è il vero sarebbe da 100 89
[Musica]
tifi milan
chievo
niente scuola la purificazione
[Musica]
lo sa che il valore di quanto
cosa bisogna fare niente
dobbiamo scoprirlo tinti a vuoto bene
numeri dimostrano non ne ha voglia parte
xf
perché ha una crisi di nervi attivo
vabbè si è scattato un self i
graffi rachel e berisa beach ma mi
sembra molto 13
ai fatti una foto
mi fa troppo ridere che tipo quando
guardi le cose e adesso non si vede più
l'inquadratura sempre stoffa come se ci
fosse una videocamera che lo riprende
non si deve far riflettere è stato se
illuminati
devo fare
devo andare nel cesso come abolita
sicuramente affitti diventa di salici
campana antincendio blu 9 aprile
promosso il cortile le mani
che ne so magari
lavandino così
eccolo sei molto bravo fini lo sapevo lo
sapevo
ha visto su un carina beh se nel paesino
delle strade statici st delle scorie
picchiati torturati
hai un dono
no era vero e bellissima mamma mi almeno
una sfocata è questa marino lavoro
succede qualcosa quando uscì fuori la
farfalla ma non mi ricordo cosa no a
tipo un potere strano pronomi con la
cosa
che la farò a po di tempo forse non
ricordo cosa ciò però non era una
notizia poteri mi pare di sì ma e vai
vai vai scattato la foto poi tanto
strappi
brava
la brucia della luce ok
sono il bagno le donne infatti ma che
fai
eccome
ma veramente che bruttissimo inizio
marzo si inizia così com'è il senso ho
riso
abelli che torna al sì sì le sabbie del
tempo in al ritorno indietro
[Musica]
no mica la lezione di nuovo no non basta
però adesso lo sai
che
io posso riavvolgere il tempo
perché devo
no dai
dai dai
e
[Musica]
allora la risposta è quella che hai
detto che si apre comunque non mi sono
ben dai lo sapete
lo sai
[Musica]
max sensi capture
adesso
la da gratifica
turistiche
e brava max e l'altra
va e anche tu resa nel deretano
molto
per riuscire
però sempre
così
ero più normale
amaro
come facciamo la mia voce impossibile
che amano infilo nella non idrofono è
impossibile che
si prova sente benissimo
non
importa se mi
va bene così tanto si sentiva bene anche
perché contro l'ultima edizione
cosa vi fatto rima
enormi se ti dicevo una cosa a cena
ma poi saltarlo ok julian lennon
ma nel mondo 7 white
max
rompuy anni di fila in cod
va bene
dai andiamo a salvare la vita alle
persone andiamo e.coli cambio poteri
adesso devo andare nel bagno e svenire
di culo ma che fai
ok ma si è vista
del
gioco
ma si capisce
il momento
guardarle basta tirare
martello
bello ma dai ma è
morto
bravo
figli sia un questo coso
no b day la mia foto non credo
dati ben più bello però molto male hi
vision
enhancer
e da un po che 29 giu
[Musica]
la parola data la gente se lui si calma
telo di finte sito ma poiché era prassi
lakers poverino a quella cosa con il
face che scoprono di ogni anno fa
ma basta tutti sti problemi
è
stata proprio di un filtro nord per
l'oms
makes
me non lo so neanche io però mai
si senta signor pelato la ringrazio però
uno aveva una pistola primo il look
brusco e sky uk
facebook di max
max
ovviamente
dico io non dobbiamo e
[Musica]
non
è contraria quelle che
sai brunò distruggiamo tutto
a
me
va bene stavolta
dai browser e scelte contrarie dai
nomi repubblica
che bella segua un sacco
devo ringraziare sera però il tetto
nella mia scuola
ad acqua e cosa
mamma mia che
da
il diario
aspettato studiare non ignorarmi madonna
che palle questo che siamo donne
rimbalzo
ci sarò quello figo vedrai ma che finché
siete mai non approcciate così non
approcciate così veramente cerbo
non approccio dico che è vero che c'è
mai una mancata a sky che cazzo a un
drone che stavo con un drone altezza
uomo tra l'altro si guarda ai fighetti
scommetti
con lo sono io
tipo
sono attori dovrei leggere tutte queste
cose ma non le si va bene va bene lunedì
anna perché giorni la settimana
e dormitori
orion webcam in ciao jean non troppo a
mimare warren che warren warren va bene
non te lo trattiamo male john ancora non
sa più di noi abbiamo un cane non
sappiamo camminare in questo gioco
[Musica]
ok allora senti già nei un deficiente
l'approccio è sbagliata stato simpatico
cosa viene detto quello figo sono uguali
ci vuole chi c'è
ci voleva i capelli corti brutta un culo
che cosa fanno professore con una notte
ma è cosi
ora lo ammazzo dove di quello nostrano
si nascondi del mark mestre già facendo
questa voce
sarà anche se
sono altre due che fanno ridere e boe
non hanno senso di esistere
audiences a classi quarte file
provenienti da qui il mio 20
domenica pertanto la infatti va bene ma
che fai da te non è istantaneo hi macs
oppure
22 milioni di views sentiamo e vediamo
singh ha più l'aspetto
comunque io questa futura scali sopra
victoria
da fuori campo gli arrivano a cercarla
nel naso bruttissimo
[Musica]
irrigatore va bene quindi devo entrata
acqua immagini
dal dal retro no
come entriamo dentro avete meno male che
non ha sposato la scala
ma almeno mi date un altro entrata hobo
è ma c'è un faro sai
si è
ammalato mi piace sto gioco perchè si
pagano però non
non si deve fare qualcosa la devo tirare
lì e poi boh però a parlarle
come si fa a
fare qualcosa per forza raga come si fa
alla tua sinistra
ok
eccola ok vai
pompa idraulica
giro emanuela giro
ho capito però devono metterlo prima che
lo metta
hai capito devo ma non mettevo in salire
sulla scala prima che arrivi lui in modo
che quando lo mette va giù
ora sono messi bene
hai visto
ma non è ce l'ha pure scritto ma lo
metti non l'ho detto io sì esattamente
ok
ok mai
deve aspettare adesso si parola messo lì
non gli cade in testa
mi metto io non l'ho fatto io
dovete distrarre il vitello
ma quanto a quanto lento questo
poi un caffè bronesi pensando zucchero
blocco si due set di
cannobio ho capito
finance day ho visto ho capito tutto ho
capito più fidati
attivare la forza prima dell'acqua
steiner seta dai attimo mi faccio andare
con due facciate netti indietro di
quelli che io premuto
non mi va p lo spagnolo seta dai altri
andrea giacometti irrigatori adesso
non mi va infatti
ma mai quanto lento
che possa accelerarlo devono letterman
omettere di irrigatore prima scommetto
di sì perché si deve distrarre
usa sella dai dai dai dai
ma io già questo ci
a scuola
ma i casi mi arriva
come te lo meriti che diventò anna stata
dai
di estrarre adesso tranquillo tranquillo
non migliorerà mai ma non
si vede ok ma sirte sfax
abbiamo ci abbiamo dobbiamo fare si può
fare si può fare gli dati fidati
testa di testa tipo ronaldo ha
detto
affittuario
prendi in giro in giro se lo merita
troppo
brava
mamma mi avessi un sound effect e
vittorioso si siede ai
neo quisma lo farà con
l'italia
mamma mia prestazione avrà delle
conseguenze di tua sorella
bene se lo merita
ragazzi
però allora ascoltami questo gioco è
tarato perché i recapiti si stima delle
tv locali ho capito questo gioco è
tarato teniamo questo
stiamo scherzando è tarato per farti
prendere la vendetta sulle tue azioni
quindi loro sanno le azioni o vi è che
tu fai quindi tipo prendi in giro e
quelle ovvie ti danno le conseguenze
peggiori secondo me perché sono vi è
quindi sanno che le fonti è stato ma
quello se lo merita la troppa che va bè
quello ci sta non so stare se non
dovendo 9 da warren io devo andare in
unico lo più scusate mi
dico alla stanza e sulla sua si chiama
ma stasera quindi elemento chimico loro
il nome della zia ecco
a cosa serve qualcosa sulla chitarra che
non si
può inquadrarsi nel suono quello aspetta
il caso rosso a niente per bellezza
poiché impugno fa leva sulla chitarra
nuovo 3 chiederlo mio padre ma la fase
guardia dai rischi perché
grazie full golden per la donazione
grazie fede grazie in amber cio grazie
romina grazie pad molto gentile
sembra di semi sfanculato ricorsi perché
chiavetta allora
che cosa
c'è facebook proprio 12 iscritti rho 12
iscritti complimenti a natale del mio
stesso anno è del 95 105 brava brava max
kyle field non hai la bocca però
camera
a dove ci sono digos con chi
si
ha
grazie per lime la propria punti ma
personalmente con una macchina
fotografica
vabbè ci si svegliò né provaci già ma io
ci provo a non prenderlo in giro sto
warren pro mamma mia se non è uno
sveglio perché c'è un panda sulla pianta
anna se nasce un ottimo la paura la
panda fund io a mente masticando un buon
streep in mamma
va beh io vorrei che la chiavetta questa
azione avrà delle cose sono state la
pianta missive locale la pianta non si
vendicherà mare bisogna essere buoni ho
capito che bisogna essere buoni con
tutti però chi se lo merita devi
ammazzare va bene
dov'è la
chiavetta ragazzi
leggi guardava dvd guarda pianta libro
pellicola istantanea chitarra
pagando saia vetta
il posti
nella stanza di dana prendeva get stanza
di dana a me dal nomentana mi ha sempre
fatto ridere
ma solo al danone al budino buono voglio
veramente da nerone mamma quello dorato
dov'è la porta di da
lei e da tavano si gioia
che è tutto ok cos'ha fatto
whiting
[Musica]
è
costretto la mangia
juliet beh lei era più la faccia da
juliette pazzo lui e
lei l'ha chiesto giochino sentiamo e
ci importano
sicuro sono la risveglio i
propri mai fatto tutto il ragionamento
giuliano non la fai sempre di nuovo cosa
ha fatto decide
così sbaglio
40 possibile di strano contro l'adesione
perché fatto prima
sezione è quella
di far
soldi
dalle palle dai perché mentre serve a me
la chiavetta questo
niente
come faccio mise la chiavetta
quindi ragazzi
esco
ma non c'è un caso che ti dice comunque
gli obiettivi a prescindere è un
messaggio di domani ma io
ciao tesoro il tuo preside mi ha scritto
da me dicendomi che preoccupato per il
tuo comportamento
sei grandi non è una piccola più o meno
è una ragazza vale nella stanza victoria
andare a dio devo risolvere i vostri
problemi
io devo risolvere i loro problemi
l'ho io cosa non don matteo
non ho capito
io però mi sono guarda tutta l'ultima
stagione tutti gli è piuttosto però si
tifa i due più due ero capisci
fosse persona scomparsa tablet
fotocamera fotocamera dai la prendono
vediamo io volevo [ __ ] fotocamera da
gente non
prenderle mail
quanti iscritti cia lei mamma mia la mia
e lido di shaun stile il 95 hanno tutti
la mia età sono tutti miei coetanei va
male desisti rimane invece gioia
don favi
sappiamo bene come la stampa
come si stampi meno male che c'è quel
tasto di perché nella vita reale non so
stampare le cose non sono sempre
problemi sempre problemi a stampare
infatti vado sempre dall'edicolante del
browse e noi anche lei di koh lanta
problemi sono la loro non ce li ha non
lo hai mai ci mancherebbe
desidero compenso viene
stimolanti poco tecnologici
andammo
dialogo tale presa l'hanno presa la
chiavetta no che non ho la chiesa c'è la
dana bro
io devo portare a mail a lei adesso che
si leva dalle palle entrato da nappi la
pietra il test
of course
a
new york
e che darà sono due personaggi di
smallville
ma come fai guardare queste cose però
svolto
bellissimo non capisce niente avevo 10
anni conduce anche io
il test di gravidanza
ma lo prendiamo vediamo sarà mica
incinta
che incida flyin fink io prego
si è
sinora dai un attimino questo ward
monatti organismo non so che la mia
musica certo
la chiavetta devo
vai via vai lì avevo succede non devi
dietro nel tempo via della chiavetta
allora devo trattare bene warner me l'ha
chiesto già andremo per
fare la parola donna pronto a darti
vulcan a
soccavo
no però
succede nulla
quindi ne vado e basta
che faccio dalla mia mente torna
indietro niente eh vabbè me ne vado da
me ne vado
me ne vado e basta a volte basta niente
torno indietro
costante nel tempo
sicuri
world days auguro
brutto però così
nella tappa che possa anche evitare di
farlo se non ora è anche secondo me c'è
un se c'è un modo secondario e ti
permette di fare perdonare da
tutto
ok niente cosa con della chiavetta e via
ma il progetto presso un bar mirò grande
uscita ma ci sono signore degli anelli
ma
i riflessi sono fatti benissimo ed è
rarissimo trovare un gioco strano
riflessi
gli ho fatto e quanto il genio questo
posso contare le macchine più scrivono
messaggi più ci metto brano bellissimo
verissimo quanto vero quanto la gente
non capisce mai una sega allora dove sei
ma quando ti stai scrivi premetto più
tempo che sai che se in realtà io sono
quella persona che arriva sempre sempre
in anticipo
ragazzo
io non ho sbagliato da subito ea
cosa riporta
hanno fatto niente vabbè
ma tutti dicono torni in giorno il tempo
vittoria
ma quello che hai
traduciamo di [ __ ] spero ti sia
piaciuta la foto per k era l'ultima xk
xk posso scrivere ti prego ti prego ti
prego
questa mi scatena quello con la pistola
ma non sanno che io ho il potere
e
ste cose
ora il presidente detto il preside
si è
preso tutte le persone che pagano le
palme
ciao giulia grazie alla donazione da
nano ti ricorda qualcuno conta neanche
intervieni no facciamo ormai guarda la
foto rega non intervengo sono pigro
timidi corrodano la ferragni
no
perché lancia padana o
quasi stanno dicendo non fare le musiche
mentre mi sa che siamo un attimo in
ritardo su studiare questa arriva prima
di meghni punti
eccolo eccolo ma il grande uomo guarda
lì che portanza che porta mentale quella
che porta mentazione galliani tiene ma
guarda la minchia sembra
[Musica]
da qui
facebook
ad occupare il loro senso che
no non direi veniva altresì fargli avere
la foto by
sì grazie milano bene qualsiasi cosa si
faccia un
cuscino
lui contro
visto
passare una ragazza forte di me
prova a farlo
[Musica]
libro che zidane
alzheimer ma non c'entra niente con
questa diversità
letto libri
ho bisogno di parlare i
fatti
va bene
pago già gente per farlo ora che che che
cattiveria che ha nella faccia se
fossimo non sarebbe morto
[Applauso]
che culo
ma chi è la squadra di merito e non
secondo halloween dunque
bravo bravo ma no
ma no non so dire niente è andato
neanche la scelta
[Applauso]
è però arrivato il titolo seguire o
nate in frasca e mais o ente ingres
[Musica]
oppure big italiane corso perché tanto
che gli spieghi
[Musica]
succedendo
il capitolo
eroe di sykes che san giorgio per sempre
dai demoni bucks
[Musica]
i braccialetti normali
qui c'è
non c'è il sembra non so che siamo
sempre noi a dire queste cose
ma di avere a casa
[Musica]
e lesbica davvero per la scelta giusta
se vuoi dire va bene
che bella casa sono comunque non è casa
mia ti entrano persino gli uccelli e non
ti rischiano il miur non entravano via
si è veramente lei sono è stato il capo
tenete di gente
perché deve scrivere sulle sui muri
sulla mappa di che lei una vera film
mamma mia il benevento un'area verde la
stessa maglia comunque davvero che stai
preoccupati io invece così
severamente lesbica abbiamo un problema
di posto infatti ragazzi diventerà un po
particolare
cazzo ea lesbica
anzi pure dall altezza
ciao che ribatte grande 17 oggi un bug i
miei ricordi mancati
beh
immagino che io non debba fare torniamo
un attimo poter apostata se erano
scomparse quelli che si chiama
non fosse la sua
avevo la finestra
che ci cambia per me perché fermano male
che bene in effetti
pensa come un uomo simile
cosa multipla
da inizio anno hanno siamo corto
controllare quella scatola cerca nella
scatola
con cui di magi questa persona quindi in
casa e comincia a controllarti tutto un
gioco tutto un cd così randomicamente
hai ancora
sai
non volevo farmi fare i suoi stavo
soltanto controllando ogni cosa presente
nella tua camera
esatto lei prende cose
quelle ricevendo
[Musica]
quindi
vai ma
poverino
[Musica]
oh merda
per tagliare così si
diceva problemi si perché no sincero sì
perché loro non
sapere perché
visto ma di con jefferson a proposito
jefferson e il varo e il pres marino da
tiffany
preside
le gesta di nome da cognome dico niente
attenti al signor jefferson
che brutto no metrodome non mi piace no
me no però con il migliore magari far
ridere bene
jackson
ci sta un carino
ma mai meglio di toni petroni
cerca
io sentivo affrontarli nella nelle cose
ai prof al prof e jefferson city da
iunco simpatico so che parte che dicendo
semplicemente lo la odia però
se ti permetti sono sul genere che
questa è la camera marco comunque al
massimo
rientro decisione
vabbè vabbè vabbè perché pure settore
fiore delle foto del genere sul tuo
portale ma poi la prima cosa che vedi
spena cerca nel cestino
lo sa che non paga le multe con questa
poi
andiamo avanti
si è
allora
mamma mia è veramente triste che fa mi
spiace ma sì dai
questo è lo stereo tra l'altro
diventarono
sempre va ascritto alla singola
per esplodere tutto sanders
ci dica vesco ai cd che aveva preso
prima
il professore ha civis tre punti
anyway
però io non solo imparare da solo
va bene ti lasciamo sola
la persona in giro incamerato di casa
sua
vediamo più di
tanto in tanto intenti fra case entriamo
prendiamoci di sicuro successo
abbiamo e musiche lei
vai apre adesso
una vacca prova mai
bello rivederlo troppo vetro bene
ok apre adesso
che è un lay
fratelli
il cancello io per mezzo fatto il pari
fi pi li
[Musica]
aspetta
no bloccato tutto andò parole niente no
niente volevo vedere se c'era perché
quando si muoveva faceva una faccia
strana va bene andiamo a riparare a si
sentì come velocemente parla
così è normale
tutto rotto
promesso la musichetta del danone in
testa non è mai possibile che tra
l'altro è il sound e fletcher comunque
comunque novità di dove sia gara
ma questo gioco ha delle pause
[Musica]
esistono tra un capitolo e l'altro
perché
se non lo dobbiamo fare noi il nostro
sono stati cinque ore così siamo tipo
quasi a due ore quindi la facciamo però
non so bene ogni quanto a power gli
attrezzi
[Musica]
con la roba di profondi capello
la benzina a credere che non favorisce
un bastone quel cartone
ora
però
al mini 20 ma sempre dice questa è
l'ottava
perfetto
vinci
contro il psg di kate
ma mannaia sanzioni vastola ciò la foto
infatti all'aula toto posso farlo ci
torna adesso farla vedere un attimo con
te quel casino quello che me che picchia
il mio ragazzo
no no no abbiamo fatto la foto basta o è
quello che sta dicendo quello che avevo
detto io
il pescato tira
una mano adesso prova a montarla 600
volte vedo quando funziona siamo portati
risulta mai chiudere un iva inclusa new
way
[Musica]
mi metto a
pixar
noi
poi scatta restare security
ma allora lo dobbiamo no no persona foto
quella foto dobbiamo
questi scafo prendiamolo prendiamolo il
carpi sharing non puoi prendere che cosa
che lui era un ex militare ecco perché
poco per figer
o
no dobbiamo buttarci chiara la mamma mia
dominarmi
[Musica]
coso prestazionale dei conseguenti
guarda
la telecamera nella stanza di naufraga
vedi ci posso credere
che poi non è un
un posto così segreto può essere un
cassetto
na li
lo chiudi lo scoppio da lei
vorrei chiudere sotto
ma
avremo tutto avevo tutto
ogni informazione ricevervi potrebbero
essere la password del computer
non si può scrivere si farà finché ho
sbagliato sono i soli a che fare con la
testa per forza qualcosa che era
forse prima si deve
dove vado di preciso spiega matteo qua
al tavolo è no allora
no bisogna andare intanto a ripararla è
quello che stavo facendo
quello volevo fare termina che mi sono
persone attimo non devo non devo fare
[Musica]
c'è anche a segrate milano non devo
imparare la
camera adesso la mamma che proviene
varela camere da letto intanto
memo è successo ai
gay che un cassetto
no
no è cassetti
tocca ex swing piastrina dei veti mazza
buona
vabbè ce n'è un altro cassetto
o morto ciò è stato dello shrine union
minacciati
e non è
le relazioni che per l'ibl 1 si sta
votando al 39 st un attimo me l'ha fatta
va bene
va bene non mi date con un sinistro
ragazzi e giorgia anke io vorrei
incontrarti
facendo grazie jessica della donazione
vista proprio di ogni giorno grazie
anche a te però che mi strappato un
sorriso ogni volta che il lego lego
messaggi deliranti voglio un mondo di
bene anche io
grazie ed è tornata da chloe per farmi
aiutare a me tra posto dice di
ricontrollare le cartelle che erano
cadute e no e son cadute bisognoso di
inserimento chiama sì però devi stare
calma
ci fai la
questa scena
vabbè diciamo
sì
perché
prego ciao max
zero
si
[Musica]
no
con importante
a dei proietti come
confesso
che
anch'io
io qui
si pone
[Musica]
vabbè la tipa è veramente che imbarazzo
che imbarazzo comunque di essere meno
seggi credo ai ma lol del grassi serena
delle nazionali spiega l'attrice non lo
spento si andrich
minchia
grazie
allora quando fai una live di fornai
facciamo allora io grazie per la
donazione tantissimo visto che il
gigante grave rimane molto gentile però
per quel privato a forza diciamo che
uscirà un video martedì su questa cosa
di martedì guarda al dito te lo dedico
li vede martedì è dedicato a te
ed è su corner
spiego il perché non volevo
quindi guardo milito e le squadre non
hanno sperato
pronto
allora io non ho capito se fare la foto
ai però aspetta non ho capito se
ci sono delle pause non sa perché sarò
io ho sostenuto la farei scenderemo
piuttosto male
facciamo
[Musica]
falla
questo fatto
classifica ma
veramente
in partita anche se stiamo ballando in
due
no dai non vuoi ballare è
veramente brutto non voglio morire ci ha
dato il padre che si è incazzato di
bestia
[Musica]
sì sì
vabbè ormai
fatto un bordello
raga non lo so non lo so il letto non lo
so
buona ma il
fallo
è
andata meglio
di quanto mi
sono perso la donazione
ce la facciamo
da un attimo ragazzi pausa un attimo
siamo tranquilli
allora grazie
prego grazie grazie pinze princess al
atari e lalut ariel principessa lata
riela vai con la sua detti che se
meravigliose grazie principessa la
carriera anche tu
nonostante gli avrebbe lasciato nove
mesi fa sento ancora la felicità addosso
ma che si chiama chanel chanel molto
come come lo fanno anche però malgrado
io
spero succede succede di nuovo che
succederà un bacione
ciao principessa
luca cipolla
grazie mille
grazie la b grazie samuele giorgio tutti
e due
grazie angri
proprie due ragazze facciamo una micro
pausa perché sono andiamo avanti tutta
la vita ps
[Musica]
5 minuti dieci minuti c peci.mi di 5 10
minuti massimo dai esageriamo torniamo
alle 427 dai
magari alle quattro e mezzo sono tredici
minuti
vi lascio un attimo entrò in pausa e tre
motivi
[Musica]
tutto però dovuto
dalla tutto
[Musica]
ho qui
tv
[Musica]
finta
ok
[Musica]
[Applauso]
già
giallo siamo tornati perché a [ __ ] we
are back per becks gli all blacks siamo
siamo siamo siamo siamo birre di marca
se barca lores fire ritardo magari
ritardo siamo qui siamo io e allora
allora dài
vediamo un po
andavo in debiti dovreste essere pari in
cui comunque abbiamo capito altri troni
e in un'ottica molto simpatico
molto simpatico
allora
noi a
rimanere
giorno mi parla comanda ma se sky fatto
quando e perché dalla finestra perché
avete dei problemi tutti e dodici della
seris predire la minestra
puoi risolvere la prossima situazione
familiare invece di uscire alla finestra
no esatto bravo ci sono le pistola e le
finestre ballo scappare dalla finestra
possiamo tornare viene necessario alla
messina ma magari magari
c'è il mare
prima la milano non c'era il mare cielo
certo male messina grigio milano
boh
lo ha detto no
tradotto come lumaca
va bene
grazie all'azione faville scelte farebbe
bene aiuta la gente espone molto di più
le zone lo farei ma fare così
uscirebbero 89 live
la5
di no anche se magari sarebbe più bello
approfondire però non posso leggere
tutto non posso fare perché se no
veramente secondo video interminabili
cioè non è giocare estrin mare non è
come giocare basta
però grazie
cercheremo comunque di fare il più
possibile nonostante
siamo in live
erano a
mano grazie ai seggi
della chiama ha scelto cavallino e
warren che palla sokkary preoccupata per
me
bodies altre vacce
te lo chiedo a favore grazie per oggi ti
chiamo il calar di capital art promesso
di ancora parlamento segreto che questo
non lo so ma questa non è uguale che non
sotto la torre ragazzi ditemi cosa vuol
dire uguale che premoli re uguale kakà
usciamo
professore solo a chi perché no escape è
bello sto posto già pila di roccia no
aspetta che succede sulla sinistra lì
a roma
si
no
sediamoci
strada
queste cose
ma chi gioca a taranto
gestiamo memoria per cui
la mia
[Musica]
n
mamma mia
[Musica]
pic
nic
[Musica]
quindi
e se stessi o poiché mai mai ciò
m s max l'effetto supernova di oggi
forse questo è fatto leggermente meglio
no
non c'è
rosa che viaggiano
questo
[Musica]
torno alla mia che paura mi chiese con
la roma mario
stop robot
pro team ma se noi no sì non mi ha
schiacciato
ora come si
basta
sacchin turi avvolge il tempo ma stai
fermo che sicamente
no
sono stati bravissimi
senza neanche riavvolto
come muore
non è volata una barca
giornale mi chiami sta accadendo il faro
in faccia
leggiamo giornalai leggeva in un momento
del genere il giornale una volta fatto
l'atalanta
viaggiato
i quattro giorni è successo sco portello
penso che lui ha detto ciò che conta è
ora
morti
o mamma mia
[Musica]
molti poi no poi con noi ma esilio
lo so che non sei altro tuoi soldi
[Musica]
94 inter
tutto il mio marito mica me non esistono
e sono ben 25 gradi in bella mostra di
sé in
questione
[Musica]
sforzano di tenere
ma gliela miglia ha detto già del potere
si fa lei non ha reagito male buona metà
del
[Musica]
be nice
ma basta semina
[Musica]
c
no
no tavolo le bonifiche
o
[Applauso]
[Musica]
le ali
jefferson
sono
con forza
se non sia completa senza nessun
problema
[Musica]
fashion
scomparsa ma se avevi che si allora c'è
il fine capito
ma come
no
ma cosa finché quale vermi aiuto come è
possibile
no non essere sicuramente c'è e questo
capitolo 1 è solo capito ok ma spetta ai
nascosto la verità è invece il santo 300
denunciato un altro ho preso in giro
vittoria al consolato vittoria se la
tratta per cento ma che fa siete persone
inutili abbiamo fatto tutte quelle che
hanno fatto di meno gli altri io sono
orgoglioso di questa cosa beh quasi
tranne questa esatto per cento contini
secondo me tipo cinque persone hanno
fatto questa cosa
alcuni sono rimasti nascosti perché noi
non ci siamo riusciti alla schola
nasconderci
che figata si poteva anche uscire allo
scoperto intervenire
si può giorno e sempre finito se va bene
wow
hashino
santi next next gas quindi c'erano
serafini capito
siamo sempre da zero
perché finita lì quella lì va bene
l'episodio dai dai dai al times facciamo
o mio dio va bene
potremo installare ragazzi dove siamo
devo installare il seguente momento che
con due piloti a perché il primo
episodio era free mi sa che lo devo
comprare il secondo
[Musica]
dai peggio
ma non c'è un modo e poi prendere
e ma tanto prima o poi vi farò tutti di
sì
il sito
dici che dove sappiamo ne costa meno
certa al controllo poi vediamo
arriviamo dovevo prenderlo ma perché
l'ho messa così apposta per nella web
che non ci vediamo tutti e due sfilate
sempre si porta comunque piace comunque
una molto bella levy strange ea me sta
piacendo molto molto bello purtroppo non
possiamo andare approfondire ogni
singolo episodio al massimo che avevo
giocato tempo fa su un porta questo di
nolan no non ho giocato due minuti
perché in cui portatile la gava
tantissimo detto vabbè lasciamo bertè
beh mamiya e beh
non è che adesso un casinista alla ru le
cose non bravo tranquillo ed ebbero
a perché questo
bene una bomba molto bene e
speriamo era aveva scusate un attimo
veit
sì lo devo lodevoli devo scaricare in
realtà infatti vi mette un attimo mi sa
che mi metto un secondo in pausa e dc
ed emettono syraka al 5 minuti in pausa
perché lo devo scaricare si è un po un
casino ma è meglio la pausa ma cosa c'è
solo
lo scarico e niente lo metto una datemi
cinque minuti e dura ed ora i was right
mettiamo un po di musica per farvi
rilassare nel nome let's go
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ciao raga
guardate me mi li sta scaricando tutti e
cinque perché non può scaricarne uno
solo li scarica tutti e cinque
perché io in teoria non penso e non lo
puoi scappare in modo da far scaricare
uno solo vero no quindi aveva scaricare
tutti e cinque perché si sta scaricando
tutti e cinque quindi sono tipo
adesso vedo se se riesci a partire
quello stesso a partire anche cioè senza
scaricarli tutti
se no dovete aspettare tipo alle 5 10
perché scaricato
scaricare tutti avere ora niente
ci vediamo quale 5 10 perché li deve
scaricare tutti ci mette una ventina di
minuti dice 19 minuti 19 minuti ci mette
quindi alle 5 10 5 10 ha finito qui ci
vediamo le 5 10 larga perché delle spine
di scaricare tutto è troppo e li scarica
tutti ci abbiamo tutti a da 5 10
torniamo pausa forzata però poi non ne
facciamo più all right quindi dopo non
ne facciamo che tiriamo dritti però
doveva fare la pausa forzata adesso
perché deve scaricare e non sapevo per
per dati non sapevo dovesse scaricare
dati pensavo ci fosse già tutto
il gioco quindi scarichiamo e torniamo 5
10 siamo qua
[Musica]
[Applauso]
cesa
[Musica]
beh sì
questo
va bene
i beni 6
ma se roma
sveglia
[Musica]
no
[Applauso]
[Musica]
jericho
marino
[Musica]
roma
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ma
male
[Musica]
sì
ragazzi 8 minuti e ripartiamo 8 minuti
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no
[Musica]
il joystick
[Applauso]
[Musica]
no
[Risate]
[Musica]
no
jarinje metti la rubrica
avete sentito vari dj
m2o ragazzi benvenuti su m2o benvenuti
sulla radio dell'amore sull'odio della
passione no non è vero numero perché
allora non hai mai dire mai non ho 40
anni che sono quasi morto accendi così
quindi a 40 anni se quasi morti né ovest
rai posso ancora fare quello che voglio
della mia vita però meno nel 93 che
punto è e ancora vivo se non è venuti
l'ametista mentalità allora amici ma
come vi dovete
scusare per questo problema tecnico ma
eccoci qua penso di avere il gioco pieno
invece non ce l'avevo dovevo scaricarlo
qual è la sola episodi uno per
l'episodio dove ho dovuto fare un po di
i bordelli se io non tolgo la musica e
continuare a tenerla dubstep mentre
gioco potrebbe essere il problema magari
l'accordo ma adesso a questo problema
non c'è più perché appunto la
stendendolo no ma l'hai tolta no no devo
andare col morso toglie la ride siete
pronti per continuo di
live abbiamo fatto l'episodio 1
il welcome for the second exor
si no 1
sì ma l'audio decide di sentirsi molto
con i premi ok ok premi 7 pulsanti
66 67
bravo
ragazzi giorgio e grazie matteo per le
donazioni
[Musica]
con giorni non ciò che continua dovrebbe
per meritarsi mi sono mesi sono
installati
ecco questo è il
dietro
il
make up per avere l'occhio nero
ma io non ho capito li stavano sta fuori
si passa ci stava in sé non l'ha detto
ma non sta palesando meno le avalliamo
da
zero
max o mia vita
sì la versione
ciao chiara si sei sempre una
principessa perché scusa perchè perchè
io devo detto prima
la principessa certo anzi un nome
stupendo
[Musica]
io non so se io sarei troppo felice se
mi dicesse un george se un giorno mi
dovesse dire sei una principessa mi
manda un bacino
io sono troppo felice del suo hascisc
grazie giulia rizzi anche felici e
semplici grazie giulia
hi fi 3g stupendo mi sta stupendo sta
prendendo troppo questore e visionare
continuate così un bacio scusami per il
problema tecnico giulia per un po più le
sei molto gentile dai ritardiamo questi
aspetti che abbiamo che l'ora di
iniziare questa seconda avventura di lei
ti strange cosa c'era in campo che
abbiamo preso
il caffè cappelli il nero caffè o
[Risate]
squadroni a sidi fatemi un tale limite
non si era capito era
sai cosa vorrei fare noti mi
cosa vuoi far partire da working ed i
due però il perché prima mi ha rotto il
cazzo non poi tipica brava così morto in
dead era tipo
tipo tipo dai distretti tipo tanto
si ma non mi devi rifare la
intanto le piante bellisario ti ricordi
hanno avviato la pianta questa cosa farà
delle consegne vero e chissà che
conseguenze ha avuto e non ce l'avrà
negli altri episodi sono tutti collegati
e non è quella m cioè le scelte che ho
fatti cifre svuotano quanti una pallina
mamma mia si vede aiuti i 5 milioni i
mastri
ma vorresti sto pigiama si
cerca invece una torre si è giocata
geniale queste il pollo e poco felice
spaziali
released salmo non mi salvo che se ci
sottopone è tutto tranne che salvo
essere una superiori non scorrono volta
scusami in secondo o bisogno di una
donna era uno storico lavoro mamma mia
zia dora a barre e non lo so
www.dell.it quello questo prodotti da
dall allora prodotti da logico perché
vorrei in una nota è
pure due
episodi non è finito eravamo qua ma va
bene
nella mensa di max operato o
maxi stato un blackout
dicevano come call of duty
delmona vittoria
allora in situ ascolta musica di merda
primo secondo si fa fare i compiti da
una che sculetta così ss le fa rifare il
si fa fare i compiti
se ti rendi conto e si veste male
perché si veste male
non obus all'infinito dai succedono
queste cose
ma poi c'è una frase di gandhi la non
era a cazzo voi allora sveglia immagine
no no no oil bang for jesus
vabbè
ama tua madre
vabbè rifare la dolce questo è un tipo
ma assistiamo con la porta aperta di
noci vedere da tutti io non farmi faccio
più domande lì con te dovrei farmene
dove si
domandano se il rail orche da lei mi
vorrei giurato c'è la doccia 2 minchia
acqua la doccia e pubblica avrai capito
bruttissimo però non posso senti l'aci
nel bagno sotto per terra c'era una cosa
carta igienica guaina che spazza stipite
questo dopo neanche vino lavora anche
visto
ragazzi provate cd intanto questo sì sì
sì personale inglesi però magari più
veloce
ok basta
che succede e non solo di chi la lancia
ha lanciato chi hanno visto
ma chi ha lanciato cosa
da dove è uscita con la carne dj in fact
ma
adesso succederà qualcosa dove la carta
igienica espone così l'avana insomma
va indietro
ah ah ecco
ma perché la gente si ma per quale
motivo sul perche non posso dire vedere
ma sì certo
ma rimandando la morte infatti
mondo
quest'azione va bene ok agli volevo
entrare il bagno io volevo entrare nel
bagno la smetti di ballare paese questo
non
è il simbolo della cosa se un giorno
fatto male
e best
[Musica]
buy max
perché no roma ancora ferma cerchiamo
una persona sociale a sociale a sociale
mamma di
pillole contraccettive bravo a rosa per
il vero sì quello farei di vista allora
ci vado ecco
noi dovremo andare una fiera dove io
tipo faccio il cosplay di marco e marco
fa cosplay mesi karen quella stazza e la
stessa sì certo capisci perché ho detto
in quel mini
mappa di migliore sono del nord che ti
prego ma continua caro
bending
se uscendo perché quando c'è la doccia
in pigiama però si deve fare la donna
della tua camera non succede non c'è il
bagno in camera e comune
allora che non siamo dietro vedo
non mi so propio d max ecc vabbè persona
più triste del mondo accanto determinato
non ci sono i vestiti da cambiare credo
o se no
dico più fondi che sono piste
bagno e il corridoio a sinistra e ma non
entrava nella dove leggi telefonate
infatti che
se che ha scritto
40mila utenti o peggio per te
aia devo andare da chloe non sbagliarti
come in camera mia vabbè
ci vediamo a di natta 40 minuti
sì però devono smetterla di abbreviare
così ma erano i ragazzi di 10 anni fa
quelli non adesso buon compleanno maxi
né
mai visto il fatto della pianta
ma perchè non rispondi e tua madre
la fiat ha
già in casa e scarola
what
avrà delle conseguenze
grazie di non mettermi trascritta ma
dimettermi sono la farfalla
va però io sulla sinistra lo cena inizia
sulla sinistra ma qua sinistra non c'è
niente
dolce c'è allora senti voi vuoi giocare
tu no giocatore non mi permetterei mai
di giustizia c'è kate parlarci parlaci
subito
perché già
spariti
sì ma censureranno e mario
va bene
copia
[Musica]
coi capelli sempre di plastica che so
che non si muovono forse cosa accada
erano veramente appiccicosi nella
vallata mai già tipo no niente
qui tuoi tipi miei tipo i tuoi con la
panna liquida con la palla di cannone
oddio che ricordi
da vendere
ok ora il momento di intervenire non
possiamo rifare del male a come gara max
siamo in un momento non importa
aiutano imporla fai qualcosa
in pista il sunbay ma poveri
vangelo di tutto
ma a
prescindere
da
chi dovrebbe essere chiunque da dietro
vabbè
[Musica]
però continua a sponsorizzare i siti
il video di kate punto com
quella del sito che ha scritto
creato un dominio pubblico già si è
asciugata già nella roccia tra l'altro
ma come fai ad asciugarti nella doccia
non hai gli asciuga non hai niente è
vero che ci ha spinto che fa che
poi si è dimessa la roba sportiva bensì
infatti ma che fai
sai
a perché stava facendo caso è giusto
stagione
cancella a questo
brano che bravo
vabbè mi vado a cambiare
dai manca comunque una scritta di
obiettivi
sindaci dei premi le top però sono sul
tappeto
ab
ma se a pagina 12 su 24 dovrebbe esserci
una roba di obiettivi dice più o meno
cosa fa metti anche che uno sia
allontanato per sei mesi che sto facendo
da quanto si può fare per come è non lo
so prima in un letto qualcuno aveva
detto del genere
ce vado a sentimento per sapere come
funziona
ma come ti permetti regista mediocre
filthy vuol dire
ai
profili
vestiti verona
amen e video non sempre gli stessi
raccordi queste due miss mentalità da
youtube
una tenia
qui non c'è cosa che io ad esempio
adesso non ho capito che questo cercava
type r inter per farti capire
cioè magari non sono stato attentissimo
al cento per cento ci sono sulla ma
magari mi sono mi sono perso una una
micro cosa come tipi
ma la chitarra
a obiettivo è qua bisogna trovare il
libro di gaeta si devo dare cosa che
giustamente quindi non pochi
ecco bravo
ma si
diventa un software inc
il mondo abilità ai siti online
file mittente sbarchi che informa
che in sostanza numero privato
iniqua boccacci in pazienti chiesa sarà
per di partenza dove dormi come mi fai
paura
tanto non puoi mandare messaggi in
privato o in di eliminare sprechi e
senza di stella michelin senza di giulia
come briani bari per i giochi che
io n
poverina non se lo merita senza soldi
e
basta io
volevo delle prove a quota proteica
questa new face
abbiamo come massimo in quanto è facile
questi strumenti mente di ferro
con i problemi
si il gelato si so che funziona
che mi dici del video quello dove si
rivalgano
limonato è per noi un sacco di ragazzi
limonato c'è un mito per i mono
non è
la prima giocata professor layton
su questo non c'è ed è perciò
non ricordi quindi
denunciata
[Musica]
nel mio tempo fa abbiamo preso un
coniglio in casa nostra
si
allora foto
no allora volevo dire
scusate mi sono letto stavo guardate
ascoltando leggenda
ascoltando sentendo i fari con sa bene
tutta la stanza di kate e memorizza
perché a te per tutta la statuta las
tutta libia veneziane itway cimentati
qui dentro è tutto troppo è
la bibbia
e fan di gesù
infatti
libro
permesso
sì sì sì
una pistola
scontro
jonathan è stato poi ne sto affetti
dalla polizia proprio
allora
secondo
sentire in colpa
ma che cosa succede mamma non lo sapevo
vedi tutti dicono no non bisogna vedi
dobbiamo fare tutta la cosa opposta
tutte le cose opposte mi dispiace ho
sbagliato
guardiamo
[Risate]
le cose su kate tipo foto con le sorelle
minori di una so dovrò allora si è
invece
di 60 con la meretrice agli occhi di dio
io e la mia parrocchia pregheremo per la
tua anni mamma mia perché tu possa
venire disponete dalle fiamme
dell'inferno grazie zia non hai
sbagliato anche il mio nome si che mi
chiamo kate senza la gag però va beh
probabilmente un diminutivo tipo gatti
lorenzo e loro in succo capisci di
bocchetti si proietti è tolto una
lettera sola complimenti siete
contro un attimo una foto
allora andiamo ad analizzare padre madre
e due sorelline
ma qui una con gli occhiali va bene
niente ricordiamoci vagos
mirino
keys ajdabya wine henry moning ci sta
qua suite che peccato piace più poveri
di homo montino minute super io posi
o cromata santis nonna
tuo padre che abbiamo ricevuto una
programmata adeguata la preside riguardo
alla tragedia non si locazione con
chiamate oggi a fine delle lezioni
pregheremo per te come sperato perché
rai per il nostro perdono
cosa prega per noi peccatori cibo
e traumatizzato
ora questo che brutto non ha neanche i
capelli blu
ma c'è un potere di gesù
non avrò e jared leto è vero
che i cacciatori in parte
niente
guardati sta andando basta questa
un'altra foto ha mostrato che qui ci
sono
queste che quando sorride di nuovo c'è
da così
esatta così vabbè
vabbè
mi dispiace mi dispiace
l'obiettivo ma perché non ce la fa clic
ma ma se ci sono 22 le balene chip edili
ma
queste cose non mi ha veramente un sacco
di problemi
vabbè
ma no
no perché gli chef che non usciamo bene
cosa succede
altra foto sono due le foto 2 foto
effetti abbiamo visto
altro cinematica bella questa è la
scuola che ti abbiamo visto almeno sei
volte lui a
praga e un con cui vorrei fuori presenta
rovai un gioco a bivi nel senso che se
tutti mi dite e fate fai una cosa fai
l'altro fair e diventiamo scemi che
questa la mia strada nostra strada
quindi da queste warren guardan ciao zio
come valore
hai sempre avuto occhio
per occhio
che è un super o e quindi magari lui
in
studio
ci prova in tutti i modi a dal ricordo
ma veramente
cosa vuol dire scimmia legami ma cosa
vuol dire
veramente guarda darei pure ma spiegami
che cosa vuoi cosa vuoi dire comunica
con me in modo normale dio
bo grazie martina la donazione da
hendrix grazie mille allora ti adoro
anche io zio cioè ti vedo poco dal cono
perché se in piccolo non sono io non
vedo niente però di non andare bacino
grazie molto gentile magentino grazie
the magic world of dell'olio rigori ne
sono benedetta
ho preso il tuo libro grazie amore
amore troppo si è un po troppo amore ma
un po meno
grazie avrei preso il libro è molto
genia moret full un amor fou espandiamo
c amore facebook ce l'ho anch'io vedi
lei parla come come
a più tardi colpi col più mamma mia
ragazzi e ragazzi molto gentile
creato questo è tutto questo non abbiamo
ancora fatto una lezione meglio per lei
jus et fucking
hate o internet no
alla morte colori che si parla con
l'altro in due imbecilli chi c'era nata
quel deficiente la pistola e parlavo il
papà di cloe
uno più mongoloide dell'altro
pongono fine alla loro vita insieme
scegliere questo pare che i capelli ci
sa
cos'è non solo da boe hanno aspetta un
carrierone non è l'autista
non so
perché l'ho vista del cappello
ma ho
la musica come se stesse per succedere
al coro di mente
questo non lo conosco spiega
questa scena magari a zero
è la madonna
cesareo c'è il faro
succede infatti che strana fisica
non è mai vista sta scena
c'è lei che guarda poi la finestrino
famosa per quando tv ha degli occhi
e lo so davvero ridere comunque o il
personaggio disegnato avvio
ed io
vabbè infatti il suo zip artista molto
zitto sto faro sembra che l'udi guardate
non il contrario
che vuol dire tutto questo non capisco
perché dovrebbe essere famosa questa
scena e lei che guarda fuori dal
[Musica]
mas questa anche questa questo pagati
ma forse come che ne so
non creare giochi
le due balene in
[Musica]
due parole
usate guarda donna e uomo è
stata una società con un disegno di un
pesce veramente pessimo
pessimo ribollio
perché sono andato subito nel cesso
una domanda particolare
l'oro come vi siete conosciuti tue
signor gatto
qua c'è scritto una cosa orribile
box
io il signore atto città e perché io
giocavo spesso nel server dei
termosifoni dove lui gioca spesso quindi
sono usciti li tramite anche karim
di
arrivo no no
basta
però il messaggio veniva dunque
sono in ritardo prendi un posto alla
fine alla ritardo lei a lo spero serva
un privilegio prodotti con i mezzogiorni
che ore sono gli 840 babbo suggeriamo
cioè
mi prendo un posto al sole da mi chiedo
mica justin uguale a justin bieber tra
l'altro che di identico prodi è identico
fra i rei senza gli occhiali alla
barbetta da baffetti uguale uguale ti
dico
un costo
ieri che belli questi quando fanno
schifo secondo me a livello di germi ma
loro se veramente vi americano
l'ecofin
[Musica]
scuola
si
no
[Musica]
thiene che va bene facciamo
mangiare effettivamente ho mai detto è
perché di sicuro lo prendi un baffo
l'ala belga che non sono
felici o capi caffè bacon caffè beh come
lei mamma mia è la cosa più
di
tanto il caffè americano non è da meno
così tanto da far sismica
entra mercatini cuore è rimasto in
panchina
[Musica]
no però teoricamente con la figlia e
dobbiamo gioco tu puoi fare in modo che
c'è poi mangiare per ritornare indietro
nel tempo essere saggi ma non
è
l'unica cosa che non ho chiesto se la
mamma stacco
e allora perché
il
patrigno non è anche legato al
sanguinamento
persona molto intelligente
maiale ceramici bassi e verbo
grazie alle corde l'ebitda è
questo questo ci sta crisi sarà anche
tutto scritto attaccato
[Musica]
ma non siamo scemi noi ricordano questo
della pista
ma chi ha mai
capito
ok mac
[Musica]
hawking di lara gut impresso ok
ok
ok quindi chiavi
ricordiamo a max
chiave panda
sigarette monetine
warming ticket è una roba di novità
della macchina nota che anche cosa i
soldi sigarette che fumo
così stavolta con due ma
è mai
ok ma si lavora
direttamente allora ai
chiari quando sono già chiusi si
prova a 39 30 non so che non c'è dice 34
[Musica]
poi le
chiavi il nome ma mi chiedo quanti soldi
vince
schiavi le chiavi che la zona è
arricchito di sky mceachran
sigarette
quante sono mi chiede
ma [ __ ] non lo so forse 8 nodi piu
si aspettera tipo 13 pro libro
io vado in 3d 7
sì perché c'è un
seven
segreti capraro e se che c'erano sei
sotto
che i soldi e la fine i soldi alla fine
sommano come ha invece fatto a marchio
butta 82 86 82 e ic senso
di max
montarli ha scritto anche scritto un
attimo indietro un centesimo 5 centesimi
sono sei in quartieri gol a 25 centesimi
25 no aspetta questi sono un quarto di
dollaro c'è scritto qua 15 e quindi sono
6 centesimi un quarto gol avevo sono 25
centesimi 25 31 no però ti sta dicendo
questa è la leggenda delle cose qua ci
sono quattro quarti di dollari quindi 25
ben cinque un quarto d ora lo è ma qual
è la leggenda sole sorgere
ok sono 50 sono 100 centesimi un dollaro
quindi ha già più di prima già quindi
esce ma
allora un centesimo 2 3 4
5 6 centesimi un dollaro e 6 centesimi
aspetta aspetta perché questi tre ha
vinto no aspetta bru
questi sono 20 su questi sono 50
75 centesimi queste sono cinque quindi
80 ottavo
123456 86 86 ma avevamo tutto giusto
tutto intorno a 82 magari vediamo ma
guarda fi guarda contro un ottimo di
sigarette per essere sicuro
dice 34 si ricorderà ti ricordiamo detto
921 era la data
che sarebbe stato
si
sa che non è mica devo dire tutto
ciao innocenti non c'azzecca era una
ronaldo perdonanza ragazzi milan al
7 poi diamo tutto dai
cavi la panda
sulla destra ecco i
soldi
quanto sei le liste che sfiga per un
pride village ma che ieri è bene
uscire non ottenute 6 centesimi
mamma mia che faccia la disperata
ma
ho
detto prima
max
aspettando
niente
di
chi sto
bene se ne
ritorna ancora c'è un'altra cosa che
succede tutto e allora sicuramente caffè
[Musica]
il camionista fa cadere la nostra forza
è il poliziotto
e il suo collega se ne va
[Musica]
e già si ferma
sì
esattamente allora ora dovrebbe cadere
la tazza cosa
non riguarda la nostra guardando
però non perché qualcuno l'ha cambiato
la canzone insieme
essa cos'è il jukebox
[Musica]
che palle
che sei
[Musica]
mango enti progetto
quindi fa cadere la tazza e fiducia la
casa sarà come camionista
cappello no per il fattore la tazza l'ho
capito
il sole che se ne va
si era svolto fino al terzo il jukebox
giusti ma è il box con capitali insetto
è visto nemmeno io e la blatta la blatta
mai sulle platt
dopo che una brutta quella sopra blatta
si sia l blatt
stavolta già dalla cinematica infatti
sai come si dice blatter siciliano
ok
va bene anche queste justin iva o
costosi gesti mamma mia ma nere e li ha
messi un pò stilosi
ma per governare il bagno
bene l'uscita linea si chiama non si
usciva e forse sulla sinistra uscita ma
magari perché devo pagare
[Musica]
non significa che si paghi non si paga
provato
come si esce
[Musica]
risponde
mi dispiace mi sono fatto giocare
mt turco cristo
di sopra che devi rispondi papà mi
dispiace scusate ma mi dispiace scusate
non
si sa
bene dove zona ma coi ok hai fatto a
morire
si sarebbe se qui o meno male cioè di
reddito sarà così citare anche io sono
mamma mia
cosa di matera che ho cambiato le cose
milo salvata quella s'ammazza o
quella carica
o è questo
che vende il pesce il tizio sconosciuto
quanto crede questo
non l'ho letto in tempo a loro
[Musica]
mamma mia
tvb
non c'è una
scena
orribile
nel 2012
tra una bottiglia di liquore va beh
sì massimo non ho posto io guarderei
guarda
masse ma sopra la barca c'era qualcosa
bottiglia
ma sono anche serate la barca che viene
scagliata contro il faro fortissimo ma
come hai fatto ricordarlo tutto
con un tempo però dovrebbe come minchia
la prenda con l'asse
anche disse sua povera sei già brino
e poi si lamenta si è lamentato con me
dell'ovo sparse tina romics di fior che
la prendo l'asse e mai muovere una
critica
sono mai
semplice faccio giro ma i prof ai sto
giro
ma sulle rotaie
al treno di ricordi già rider che
l'abbiamo visto prima dai sali cribbio
ma c'era quella strada che il mondo
necessità dei proiettili per terra
lasciamo stoker altri di fucili appone
recenti tra l'altro un po
lei è
veramente sempre lo stesso postando una
facilità arcana però va bene
il padovano white america
a un'altra ma tra troppo
perché devi sparare delle bottiglie che
problemi hai non poi di pensieri di
cydia
caso
sono stati peggio drogati sì io immagino
che metterei tutti i vestiti non riuscì
già per come sono fatto io poi dove
particolare ne ho una è aspetto che
prendo la faceva lei
finiscila ma infatti ma che abita boh
ecco
la le ombre il caffè
no ti preparo
devo mettere di con materasso nella
cassa
esempio
anch'io
ok punto il double bottiglia post
aumento parola
quanto
cinque bottiglie ma no ma credo che
queste cose trova 74 monetine e chiaro
messaggio di warren aspetta fammi legge
che importante
a questa scrive messaggi non me ne
accorgo neanche non seguo
oggi questo paese o
inglese come sarebbe
aping
capite a beijing a ping
orribile
essere sta mettendo il bavaglio palo
[Risate]
ottavo xex è più ad esempio formazioni
serba foto foto
perché si vede non si sa perché nuovo
proverbio mamma mi assicuro che poi city
poi cosa di harry potter ma a prora
vedere la foto l'intervallo di navi
non ha niente
altri bottiglia ecco la
nostra
così corre e bella corsa
sfida
dove ming e sono le bottiglie sinistra e
controllato le
[Musica]
puoi sederti sul tronto
grazie ai pertici
l'attrice guarda
portico demonio che cade spaventato ecco
no no no no che ogni tanto parte
però proprio tu io sono pessimista
perché sei morto otto volte
hanno preso bottiglia mentre
sam s
gesù cristo nel mentre scrive messaggi
a più tardi
normale che sembrava bene bene bene che
ed è mia amica
c'è una casa e rientra è fatta di schifo
è già infatti testa ai tuoi figli mi
guardo nelle fonti
nei giochi su mentre qui solo il club
cielo ti amo figlia eccoci qua
buio di questo è che doveva tesoro
gorini katherine price
sì c'è scritto a punteggio
chissà chi ne ha
piene le tue fottute bottiglie
ris max
we work
in a ne aveva sei in totale
imparare bene cir ho visto
un sacco di tempo devo farci un trick
shot
ea max
che schifo fi
e wi max
max
spetta
e mi sono max
di incredibile
eccone
proprio farli sparare a qualcos'altro
ma ti capisco ma
porca vacca saperlo
abbiamo giocato gta sappiamo cosa
succede
mamma mia
quindi devo forse però la vittima della
bottiglia più
niente
o
quello
e ti sta bene
non
torna indietro torna indietro mi sono
salvato
portava che chiede mente al collo plate
[Musica]
maria
le altre volte
l'opaco
dopo che stavi per morire tu
saronno
maximus
melas
problema è già cioè un problema se sei
una persona
seduta da sola donna
vi vorrei veramente capire come
arriveranno papa cioè lei si devono
sapersi ritmi now the
mask anno fa
[Musica]
lasciamo perdere perché non si linari
col abbiamo predetto già noi
va bene dovrei parlare comunque vai
dove ecco
brolo perso
o dio
ho perso flora
sulla sinistra eccola
tutti non è la bros in là e la scherzavo
boh
si spara in aria così sono un po fuori
perchè stavamo
tommy gainey
[Musica]
juve
questa bach piacere protette
amica si doveva ammazzare dicendo libro
spara in via tenente
[Musica]
carica con la gente butta le cose vanno
i tossici
questa cosa cambierà diventò i suoi casa
il momento però è il momento che si sta
creando
in italia
john tong grazie grazie
prendiamoci una pausa e parliamo
sulle romane
sulle rotaie dove passa il treno
prendiamoci non passava altre
perché si continua come spa in quel
files
gente
perché sulle rotaie saie
no dentro
parole
[Musica]
dai
ministri
mi fanno sentire
air adobe ha
illustrato stop
qui
prima
ma questo
sta andando avanti nel tempo resta sì ma
è tornato così il prof
con android
mamma mia ragazzi ho veramente vi giuro
su dio suina nella piscina di salvarla
io cristo di dio la
mamma però me ne frega un cazzo è
detto che faceva riva non potevo non dio
si fa solo perché faceva arrivano detto
ciao dai fallo toglie
[Musica]
detta è roba là là dentro
piede di porco
un vero piede di porco ma che quelli
visti e stairway to heaven botta inglese
sta
per uscire la prima che il 30
spetta
agli enti riporto sotto ai fatti
vabbè favole che cambi dall'euro
tirati
spetta
[Musica]
bravo vederti questa scena
ragazzi non poterlo a casa a
bra esatto
me lo fanno fare
porca vacca porchia porca vacca porca
è gesù
media bonami adesso è
troppo tempo
tira dai tirare ma non è provato a
tirare la città
ma poi sono nati senso devi devi fare
forza da quei cani
[Musica]
cerca una corsa ed era ormai network
wireless a metà di denis u
ecco
tra shanghai rifiuti waste c'è anche
chloe
entra
magari come final destination nel senso
che tu puoi salvare una persona con tuoi
ma ma ecco ecco la sorte se la prenderà
lo stesso no no no ho sbagliato cassetto
volo prenderle basta
rimessi
incrociato già troppo giallo in mezzo
ma è giusto è giusto
va bene mai niente
[Musica]
grosso verde pro rossa è troppo in easy
vai
dire allora che si farà lo scotto
precisione
o
last set
mammamia pro si diceva io sei militari
una volta non si può mai dire
secondo volto nuovo
[Musica]
ok
sul filosofico
si meriterebbe latte il giardino dai la
ai giunti
deciderà il cuore
del caos
green light my
fire
complimenti
roma giusta questo
adesso
nota di ieri si sa che ora te lo ricordi
no
[Musica]
come faccio
nola senso
paolo times
sessuale
no non ha quel messaggio quello che
chiedo io ho scritto anche ora
dopo ok
ma facciamo
parte micro pausa
dai vai a due minuti minuti per noi è
stato molto figo comunque finora le
voste riuscì a finire l'episodio prima
di vino e dovremmo farlo noi
non ora un po meno po meno ne va a
finire nel caso sup e volentieri vi
lascio ben 25 minuti di pausa e torniamo
[Musica]
non perdere
niente devono cadere per terra le case
dei gruppi amici per beck
per secca
o
episodio write una ragazza si va si
manca poco
manca poco ora dice lo sento sola di
ventola fisio dc paraolimpico
nostro
[Risate]
no no provino appena facile mi arrabbio
tantissimo blow fi no
ad
esso
la banca
non
[Musica]
va bene va beh
guardi
weather
vega sono lavoratori di fantascienza
no dai nord perché
dai
sismi max
lasciati in pace
servizio
i soldi
missile
max
io
che te spaventato every bar in house ma
è vero senso io sentivo dire everybody
knows
eva
braun
[Musica]
ci sono occasioni
e il treno
tra un po d'italia
nei b b ruffoni re
io sto vendendo nelle foto
questa quale io disegno di daniel
orribile blu vediamo come schiacciate il
fantastico si limitano
a
ora mi è chiaro ma la mitica che viene
non è la lezione questa di alta si se mi
siedo che faccio io ti adoro che il hai
potuto di salina soldati che però emerge
se sì esatto
che proprio quei
mezzi che
parla con tutti
perché
vabbè
rivoluzione della risoluzione
ex
soci
raggiungo commenta
mamma mia
questa vede tutto tu mi agito non si
accorge di niente
all'occhio pinero di prima volta che
lo ha posto grande di
nuovo
so che faceva film cosa ma ero
ok
[Musica]
tutti i professori
un secondo
tipo
fuck the system
de les bien revolution mamma di sfamerà
il checker crooked house
weekend
ridotto
non si vede
poi mascot quale ne parla con le sue
migranti
mi piace che hanno un sacco di potere
sugli alunni
no però
statista ammazzati gate che se mi ha
chiamato tutto a posto non dovere oggi
di cristo
non ha neanche voluto vedere però non
pare troppo le scimmie
proprio devi fare qualcosa per forza
di un attimo vista essendo il sangue
troppo non ce la faceva oddio
guarda quella col telefono
ha stoppato il tempo si è stata
abbandonata
dai broker
e come faccio
c'è chi immagina scena una si butta giù
io dopo capitolo fatto a stoppare il
tempo
giusto ma learco demonio schivare con i
piccioni
mentre
si può fare tutto l'edificio così
colà se chiude la prendo io
che faccio
mi faccio un giro in questo momento non
stai contro nel tempo giusto no
nola mi sa che quando entra dentro entro
dentro poi no
sembrava prendere al volo magari
prenderlo un po alto
malissimo
devo fare il giro giro giro
faccio il giro ho detto faccio g no
ragazzi
non posso fermarmi dentro e dove dentro
dove
entrò faccio il giro
rientrare ma dove dove nero dentro non
c'è la porta non entra joe cole
ma dove vai sulla porta
mentre la portano soldi prendi la nella
porta a porta del dormitorio e sarà la
porta del dormitorio non è questo che sì
me lo sa ma pro saliva le scale e dai o
guardare più in alto
e si bloccava
sai che palle andare fin lì tra l'altro
colma linee statiche stai usando tutti
il massimo del tuo potere
vai
arrivo il libro
ha
chiesto che sta morendo dai dai dai dai
dai no dai fatto questo bordello orari
più in
e book
allora
io resto lo fa la scelta giusta se non
sbaglio è ok
anche smentito spudoratamente si
ami o
non farlo
se i miei mila semi a milano brough
perché è diverso perché sono qui per
tesa di
800 soltanto per questa speciale
postazione ai gay più vero in tutto
questo
nata nel
vice un nathan cominciò a incontrare
questo qua oppure stata drogata
secondo me è nata
cominciamo a fare quel posto
si
no
[Musica]
esistono miliardi di no no no se
l'opzione di parigi ne fa di più adesso
non lo riguardano
dimenticheranno mai visto mio libro
nessuno esistono
tutti dimenticheranno sii forte
no no no
e ragazzi ci ho provato dal giro
in tutta in maniera puoi tornare
indietro
accade mani ci ho provato giuro nel
migliore dei modi
ma
niente
più
ii ce n'erano e
soprattutto
forte
forte adesso mi spieghi sempre una
persona che sta per buttare giù
ok dai
domani sono a posto
[Musica]
vai aspetta aspetta questo aspetto non
l'ho incorporino jefferson non c'entra
niente a posto david ok si va di nadal
puoi firmare ma scusate sono dei
ritardati
non è che puoi far niente cioè io ho
tentato da satana io vado proposta
incolpando quanto sei un [ __ ] un
dragone
einaudi stress food and
change and roll off per
quello tentato di farlo io sai che già
vedono nto brutto [ __ ] proprio beh
vabbè
immeritato al massimo grazie the right
choice shy don matteo 11 28 ok hai un
bovino
è fallito aspettano il gene è vero le
risponderò a di telefono qazi style.it e
non è vero
anche quel bacio voi che sono salito
pure ma che cazzo stata di mons ci pensa
che sono più in colpa paesi nato quindi
la pistola do io ho detto che vi fanno
parlare sono più in colpa times la juve
in colpa
[Musica]
massimo prof che ha fatto e non ha fatto
niente
perché che ricompare il poker
avanti e finiamola
so
di dire sì forte
si fa non ci credo che si porta
speranza
[Musica]
a noi vi muovete
a breve eni finta
[Musica]
beh
sì ma ragazzi
vuoti
stanno dicendo la fine no adesso che
sapete la fine è normale che vive fai
così noi non lo sappiamo ce la stiamo
vivendo adesso quindi è normale che
magari facciamo
cose sbagliate adesso si vede il gesto
sta litigando palestra
che vuol dire chi lo sa non lo sappiamo
che un giorno capirà
[Musica]
layer e olio è dispiaciuto ma davvero
[Applauso]
ai programmi
sì contro la toscana
[Musica]
certo certo
deve essere una cosa del tipo
[Musica]
sappiamo bene
questi metodi di più
mamma mia
egli sta roba sure cielo non ho capito
il senso non si è ancora scoperto
[Musica]
e finita di merce nei sensi ci deve
portare un finire così ma è finita così
ma scusami quindi se kate sopravviveva
sexgate fosse sopravvissuta al quella
roba lì ce la saremmo ritrovata
nel gioco di tutti altri capitoli
[Musica]
quindi non si poteva salvare no se si
poteva salvare sicuramente perché se non
avrebbero smesso di kraft per passare
ball sicuramente si poteva salvare però
minchia mi fa strano che se tu la salvi
minchia per tutto il gioco in tutta un
altro personaggio cioè che a quanto
cambia tanto infatti se l'avessi salvata
cioè adesso non sarebbe creata la cosa
del
preside cioè che cosa sarebbe successo
diversissimo
c'è ovviamente la square ha fatto in
modo che fosse difficile salvarlo in
modo tale che la prima volta che ci
giochi tu non la salvo i quasi
praticamente mai a meno ovviamente non
so qual è la combinazione dopo però
abbiamo pensato che è
come non l'abbiamo queste tutta gente
che sapeva come si facevano è
impossibile infatti il 73 per cento e
lode d'annata né ok risposto alla
chiamata bravo realmente impegnato per
salvarla cioè volanti come non hai
salvato ok abbiamo salvato kate ha
capito il treno né si può fare 38 per
cento non l'ha salvata quindi siamo
nella minoranza la maggior parte le l'ha
salvata primi due mesi è impegnato
tantissimo per salvarlo fatti bo
è pronta a sparare a frank come tutti
ai disco allora fare ti spiego è morto
perché non avevi accesso a diverse
scelte perché di trattabilità bene a
tutti dimenticheranno è
a nel senso
quella ragion quella era giusta devo
dire altre cose però non ho che lei
trascurata ancora prima ma scusa ancora
prima quando l'abbiamo trascura fattivo
risposto al telefono quando eravamo noi
abbiamo questo il telefono in bagno
l'abbiamo aiutata e poi quando è stato
un po cosa c'è stato
cioè l'unica volta l'avevano tra
virgolette trascurate è stato il fatto
della foto del documento ma non l'abbia
moralmente trascurata noi vogliamo fare
la foto per poi farla vedere al preside
e dire o che sta succedendo quella roba
lì che ha detto lui
sì
io non ho capito
cosa ti sei perso no niente suicidio
ma o va bene diventa toseland airmen
che ce l'abbiamo però direi che adesso
no
che siamo stati in lei un sacco però io
farei una cosa prima cosa visto che
mancano
17 minuti io controllerei
come sarebbe andata
dai beh vediamo metlife sì perché voglio
farvi vedere cosa come sarebbe andata
insomma
allora
ma che
grazie suite cream 22 22 cross è stata
la mia orietta grazie la suite khrin
credo sia stato il miglior messaggio
finora ma che può bravissimo ma le
guanciotte rosse
adesso vi faccio vedere come sarebbe
andata a finire vediamo tutti
fa sempre ridere questa chiosa il calo
st quando la foto del
trend kate
salvare kate salvare ben noto come
trovare un video
no
che kate del kate
8 6
esta soy de jong ok
beh senza la tradizionale capitano
casomai traduciamo noi esatto come
cammini come prima bla bla bla bla bla
sì
vabbè andiamo alla parte del basta
ok non tutto
il caricatore moglie o voglio vedere in
carico dai primi caricamento
e più bella lei nella personalità messo
in inglese
inglesi
ma che figata e fermare i tagli si può
toccare le conosce per ecco
le
teste su cuba perché nella versione
nella versione
un'espansione riad esatto
ma
allora anche rinato giunti sotto la fame
esatto e io credo verso la
ok ok
affinare
le cose andranno meglio
ok my friends e
giuste mica fino qua
lo sapeva quindi tre tutto abbiamo fatto
perché
guarda che adesso se si muove io me ne
vado di qui me ne vado
no non posso crederci
mi
vedi qua c'era questa questo pezzettino
noi stavamo perché non vedo il perché
non ce la faccio prodotto mettersi a
comparire
per capirsi forte del locale
quindi se tu vedi una persona che si sta
suicidando bro devi dirle sii forte è
quello risolverà tutto tutto
si porte sbloccava 2 posso crederci i
ragazzi si forte veramente una delle
frasi più quando ti pongo semantici vi
dicono sono depresso loro voi dovete
dirgli non esserlo si sa basta e avete
riso come come per le persone che sono
arrabbiate dove dire o stai calmo e
allora sì calcio
all'hockey vito allibito se non sapevo
che stai per più alibi rus stragà
orribile sì infatti
orribile
va bene ragazzi
io
ringrazio
ringrazio giampiero che ringrazio
lorenzo vi lascio con la intro finale
così
protetto il video et labora
nava in questa max ha fatto cose che tu
non hai fatto e in automatico se
positivo dato un punteggio da sola non
ho capito niente di cui aspetta
aspettano fuori quest'anno
tu non hai fatto e detto
nel senso che da max degli di questo
video ha fatto delle cose che tu che noi
non abbiamo fatto quindi sono arrivati
costosa però la cosa abbiamo detto lee
quasi tutto giusto tenersi forte però
vabbè vabbè vabbè tariffa era di
sera era un casino ragazzi ringrazio
giampiero
grazie a gesti ragazzi e giorgio
io mi mandò un besito vi lascio dieci
minuti di altro ma
si conclude qui spero che vi sia
piaciuto cosa si ricevono mi piace anche
adesso cioè che come detto dalla
descrizione pensato anche lavoro di
giampiero che se lo chiede e noi ci
siamo
cosa fai ciao ragazzi
[Musica]
no
vecchio
[Musica]
ai
lakers
[Musica]
ora
il ghana
slm
lui chiaro
[Musica]
nell'area
il piano terra
[Musica]
[Applauso]
anche
massa
the sun mia
[Musica]
si no
così flashback
ma
gli uomini
su richiesta
[Musica]
è un biglietto
min
[Musica]
osla
o no
scuse
non fui
[Musica]
[Applauso]